Lorraine I'm I uh am 100 skeptic I don't
believe in anything Supernatural oh you
don't no who are you
if you run dead
and you don't believe it makes it easier
obviously sure yeah don't get scared I
don't really either but I want to yeah
yeah I'm open to it oh yeah if there
were new evidence presented to me I'd be
like okay I was just saying that I was
so scared of all the supernatural those
are the ones I cannot watch but that's
because I've had my self-experiences
yeah in my own personal life that makes
me a Believer and I cannot watch any of
those movies because I just get
completely freaked out she's had real
live experiences do Ouija boards freak
you out are you I will not do it you
like won't do it I won't do it I won't
play with it I won't do it or like
Bloody Mary in the mirror oh I think
that's probably [__] but I'm not
trying to do anything
she feels that she is she is a door that
opens up
the uh scary [__] yeah you've seen it
I've actually been witnessed to it yeah
it's funny that the dead meat like what
yeah she has seen things without going
into specific details sure
um we were staying in Las Vegas because
that's where I work and she was staying
in a room where she saw this needs
specific detail
go ahead okay so I was staying in a room
while he was working there
um my boyfriend didn't come yet so I was
staying downstairs in the main room and
my parents were upstairs my sister was
upstairs in a room it was a really big
nice room and I went to go because I'm a
celebrity because you were working there
I'm a celebrity so I was staying in one
of those little cots like the rollaway
bed yeah like right at the bottom of the
stairs in this room and I went to go to
sleep and as I'm going to sleep the TV
and the blinds like start turning on and
off and the lights start turning on and
off and the blinds start moving and
stuff and I was like oh it's probably
one of those high-tech rooms that has
like those crazy remotes which it was
and so I was like all right it's
probably that and then it kept going and
then the blinds started blowing and I
went to go look to see if there's air
conditioning or the thing was open and
it wasn't there was no air conditioning
vent there nothing was open so I'm kind
of freaked out but I'm still telling
myself that it's just like the high-tech
room yeah and I go to lie down and then
all of a sudden as I'm lying down all
the lights turn off the TV turns off the
light on the stairs in front of me turns
on and I hear
footsteps coming down the stairs towards
me I scream I go up into my sister's
room I'm like help me there's a ghost or
something coming towards me and she is a
science person like she is a doctor so
she doesn't believe any of that stuff
and she's like get in my bed just sleep
there and be quiet and then literally 10
minutes later she wakes up screaming
there is a woman standing at the end of
our bed I'm not joking a full full-on
woman like full I mean you can tell that
it's kind of see-through but full on
woman standing at the end of our bed we
all scream we run downstairs stay on the
couch it happens like three times where
we see this woman following all the same
no Alex wasn't there
the same woman and so the next day I go
to tell my parents they think I'm insane
I thought she was insane yeah because he
doesn't believe it he went to go I don't
know what's happening I'm staying in the
hotel and i i s I went to
um like the concierge or somebody that
worked there without her and I just said
you know my kids are staying in this
Suite
is there any history in this Suite you
know did anything ever happen and he
goes oh my gosh why are you asking me
that I'm just asking if anything ever
happened in that suite and in that Suite
A young lady had committed suicide oh
yeah and this was totally totally
separate the purse person that I was
asking had no idea that my child had an
experience in there so do you Chuck do
you chalk that up to coincidence and
they said there's a ton of people on
staff that won't go in there to that
room wow see that's it's like I I just I
want to I'm like yes I want yeah I want
that experience but give me so give me
another another explanation no I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna try to invalidate
your experience you know the electrical
stuff I understand can probably be
debunked I cannot debunk like the woman
that multiple people including my sister
who is like a science non-believer yeah
and that's just one example of what
happens to Jackie Jackie it happens a
lot
and then I'm always looking I'm a
skeptic she just called me this
yesterday I'm a skeptic of everything
you give me any piece of information I
go really yeah and then I'm that's my
reaction yeah I'll Google I look up I'm
I want to debunk everything has nothing
to do with the occult it has nothing to
do with murder and Mayhem yeah that's
who I am so I always want to see I don't
take pieces of information just
willy-nilly
that's got me in trouble with her before
because she'll tell me something I'll be
like oh okay and go to look it up she's
like you don't trust me you don't
believe that but that's like you know in
horror movies so often it's always the
the wife too who's like hi our house is
extremely haunted yeah my husband was
like and the husband's always the one
who's like it's fine like I'm I'm that
guy
[Music]